too bad you will die hi everyone my name
is Tamra chambers and this is Tamra's
never seen and today I am watching
Mortal Kombat annihilation and I'm
dressed as Queen siddell she also looks
just like this Halloween decoration that
I had hanging in my house so it's not
really any revelant
to why I'm telling you that just I
thought it was fun
hello too bad it is you who will die but
I loved the first Mortal Kombat movie I
thought it was cheesy but better than it
had any right to be definitely better
than a street fighter for some reasons
and you know Street Fighter had its own
wonderfulness but I loved it right after
posting that though everyone was like
you have to watch anihilation it's
amazing it's terrible it has a three
percent on Rotten Tomatoes which is
hilarious and I have been pretty excited
ever since I thought it would be a great
second episode of November so lush is
good on it so what okay
[Music]
you
okay so last week I watched Cat in the
Hat and I had a terrible soul-sucking
time and would never revisit that movie
this I had the most fun with it was so
flippin great the effects were so bad
the characters were so cheesy god it was
fun it was fun it was fun fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
so even after they defeated on one
Mortal Kombat and the first movie now
there are out world beings coming form
to earth even though earth is supposed
to be protected
it makes no goddamn sense and it's
amazing hell yeah Lu is back my favorite
mmm oh hello yes I wrote up even though
Lu one Mortal Kombat in the first movie
people are shooting their peace period
oh oh no the effects no no no no no no
no the villains in this the group of
villains are so cheesy and the effects
with them are so bad it's like a bunch
of theater kids in high school who had a
coupon to Party City and they went the
day after Halloween is just like loaded
up kind of cheesy I just described
myself Lou I thought Mortal Kombat close
the portal to their worlds rady what can
be closed can be reopened cuckoo cuckoo
cuckoo cuckoo cuckoo I mean that's all
we get nothing else it's just that's
that's what our reality now mother
you're alive too bad it is you who will
die amazing I want to watch it again
right now
damn it then Johnny crunch is back for a
brief moment he dies he gets his next
snatched snatched cracked what I don't
know and his glasses fall to the ground
and do like a little clang and it's very
dramatic and they zoom in on the glasses
and you're like oh shit things are real
Johnny crunch just died I brought right
notes I've said wait what's happening
like six times over but so sonya blade
or the new actress that is now playing
sonya blade is pissed that johnny crunch
is dead she's like i'm gonna go kill
who's you know the bad guy and Ravens
like no you're not and for some reason
just goes like and then like blue
lightning shoots out of his hand and he
knocks out a wall he's that come with me
oh baby see none of this makes any sense
and it's thrilling and hilarious I wrote
this is a masterpiece in big letters
then they show you a fellow spear which
is this high-tech circle that can
transport you anywhere in the world in
mere hours so a plane then you actually
see the bellows fear and it's so much
better than I could have ever imagined
it being there standing there here's one
person here's the other person and
they're like rolling around in a circle
and it's it's very sexual and just oh
yes yes yes yes fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun they harvested the energy from the
Earth's core to use the Velo sphere it's
cool guys it makes a ton of sense
scientifically and it's accurate and
just that's all we need to know I wrote
katana is hot I'm sorry that I needed to
just say that but I did I had to say it
she's hot and now we could all move on
now that I've said the thing that I
needed to say oh hey Justin long it's
not him but it looks like him then
scorpion his back and he captures katana
and he just yells to her friends suckers
runs off with her and it's amazing it's
amazing I to use that as something to
yell at people all the time then this
character named Jax shows up big metal
arms what's going on I know he's a
character but still it's just it's a lot
a lot is happening oh and yet it I don't
tap its transformers bumblebee is here
right who are you what is happening
it's this weird robot who's clearly just
a person ah
and then robot bumblebee says death is
the only way out and listen that's a big
2018 mood you guys damn then night wolf
shows up and he's like Animorphs in
to a wolf and then back into a human and
he's like pretty cool huh oh you can't
just casually turn into a wolf and then
a human they just go that's pretty cool
huh pretty casual a little cool man
pretty cool fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun then Lou trips balls Lou finds of
friends who turns out to be an enemy and
then Lou saves katana lots of Lou action
here for a few minutes it's great love
Lou god I love Lou thank you Turner hmm
oh damn that is a hair flip that is a
full-on blue hip the villain just like
full-on whack someone with her hair and
you do you know I'm saying then we find
out the Ravens dad is an elder God and
everyone's very surprised I don't think
that's very shocking but okay wow your
dad's an elder God mine is just an
asshole then a giant terribly CGI dragon
eat someone and then burps and I don't
usually like burp jokes burp bodily
function humor like that but this one
was just really well-crafted
it worked then Raiden dies then he comes
back because he's raiding you guys dad
is an elder God didn't you hear and
there's more family drama with katana
and her mom she was like my mother's
dead and the moms like as sumo beat her
daughter damn Thanksgiving is gonna be
awkward this year I mean it always is
but giant and fights amazing fight
choreo and then in giant letters I just
wrote oh my god with exclamation points
because Lou turns into a dragon and cons
sees that he turns the two dragons like
impressive but not good enough well you
need to lower your standards a bit
because it's pretty cool okay God just
just
oh my god you're never gonna be happy
your standards are so high then conjures
into the three-headed monster from
Hercules and he battles Lou as the
dragon and it's terrible CGI fight and I
wish that's not how they went out
because like the the choreo that was
happening before was really great that
the CGI monsters are just not great Lou
wins earth is saved okay right you're
not dead to the two last notes I wrote
this was such a good movie I loved every
minute of it
sisters but it is you who will die oh
maybe next week I'll be son of the mask
good idea or bad idea or amazing idea
fun fun fun fun fun fun oh thank you so
much for watching everyone I will see
you next week unless it is you who will
die bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you